hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Kristian
harloff and I'm Mark Ellis we're three
dudes on account yeah a reboot of the
three amigos this feels wonderful right
now massage oh dude that's you know I
want to be what would it be - okay well
so today we're gonna check out a video
someone made for the schmoes no that's
us yeah that's them guy named drew
planache he made this for you to show us
yeah that's awesome the favorite schmoes
no moments an 11-minute version [ __ ] so
you're gonna watch eleven minutes of
yourself guys all right Wow sorry for
yourselves more than my girlfriend's
ever watched yeah it's true ah how if
doesn't mean oh I do YouTube her my
girlfriend just doesn't love me anymore
I'll stop holding out the marriage ever
great as I'm holding out to learn yeah
well then why Easter why do you think
she's not she's not pleased with you
right now women have needs too when we
have needs
yes I learn that believe this guy and
it's a throwaway
I mean Alison duty was a far Dewey was a
farmer right I the wool nice lips you
guys enjoy the tour quick I got a guy to
think I'm gonna do this upgrade watch
you dear watch well it is my duty to
bring
come to say hi we're at a point at home
of all times the movie that actually
smelled like dude monuments Menem all
missing at it never my name is Matt Hogg
so that was that movie dude who's coming
this is week this is why you some of the
best worst year I was like you killed a
horse and I just won yeah good yeah we
good
okay I love you locked it in there no
these are like the best damn that's
awesome that's awesome and not a lot of
people saw the Dumb and Dumber one but
it was the this one wasn't as much class
yeah and scene alrights rovol this is
your turn now what do you do if he you
go to come out no no no no we're not
going to kiss you
okay what do you do Zefram there's like
John lick your nose because yeah that
was no your film last time where's but
it's been burned oh you're Megan right
oh you're ready the best part is you try
to sell it like what do you do well I'll
develop a turtle mustache in you know a
time it is
it's common time did your keyboard ready
with me announcer in our town
oh hey I didn't see you there welcome to
Grover's corner hey wait a minute love
you guys amore yes most video it out now
there's so much love that is insane does
the movie to do it I really don't do
this the movie that you want to see you
want to see him in some silly salt offer
we're going around getting it's not a
silly big open open
simply you look like very but there are
things that you don't expect to see in
hell yeah Laura Linney's gonna talent
you're watching a weed whacker this
returns has got a vital power from your
deal over cares about is a one fireside
yeah he's getting all the crack was
making a movie uh Hudson Park hi I'm
huntin for I don't know tomorrow very
poised FDR came in uh yeah it was really
good on this sunny movie I'm just lining
out your Sex in the City tooling now is
having the biggest rock take all girls
here baby
and they are I'm proud of what you're
done with your in the hair I'm gonna do
this main thing one day yeah we know why
he was been influenced oh the writing is
awful in this the first time I met Aaron
Elias make sense to me but I feel that
cartoon cat wrote this film
look out to our man you guys yeah videos
of Paul outdoors that already feature
films and this is Emma Watson has broken
our coaches Wizard of training Hermione
Granger to the elegant well-spoken woman
behind the hash tag he for she gender
equality conversation proclaiming on her
Facebook page that she is officially
signed on to portray Bell
Disney's live-action retelling of Beauty
and the Beast or as it's known in my
house the movie the tricks me into
thinking I can date
Watson has previously was previously
attached the movie Beauty which was to
be Warner Brothers version of the story
as directed by Guillermo del Toro or as
JT calls him Willy the bowl according to
the Disney receive permission from
Warner Brothers to court Watson as their
head coach after their project hit a
snag well I can wait to say to the next
time buddy go this is going to be
something that Tiffany's gonna have to
get her head off [ __ ] for a second to
think of it Wow it's not active today
she's literally just trying to exercise
it morally to get everything right that
positions are talking about male hogs
for a second and I'm going to pull that
thought out the power price compel you
to focus on love that joke
power crackling oh [ __ ] that's been a
driving game here Ken that song is gonna
have a heart attack in the burger he's
like that's gay you do know that my dad
was you know yeah dad okay I'll listen
love you don't oh my yeah you know what
that's a good size
let's talk about your dad's penis and
then we'll get right back into the best
hero it isn't I I'm not trying to run
the show for everybody else seems to be
laughing so they gotta take over I'm
ashamed of myself is that much of
letting go so I'm looking and you know
what yeah I don't say that on news oh
she sees me I'm what we're gonna do now
Morocco - what is
nobody's like war area
besides tiffany-smith families I'm going
able to ski media Reno celebrity theater
like I'll promote a gig economy in a
theater setting kids watch managers into
work oh okay I want everybody to focus
here because this is topic I came up
with and it's PG rated and it is the
best it's the best character in a
superhero film that is not the lead it
is not like the terrasse de Janiero
or the filling up you can't focus
it's like an ancillary there's no like a
like a roadie and I am oh my god like a
Wolverine will still try again because
less it will just trying so hard
something on that is the next topic so
cobster is filming the reaction I don't
even remember what I said I don't even
know about something I did I don't know
if there's like a sidebar laughs I'd
like a teacher right now that like I
don't know if they're laughing in a line
that I said or somebody in the back cut
one and everybody's laughing at that
Riley what's going on on your side of
the room right now well I think there
was a comment made about Tiffany's dad
that is Zimmer dry leaves aboard for me
I'm I can't breathe well I was going to
do that nobody but anything open anytime
a strong interest of all ticket at times
we I want to talk about the character
that is not a hero or villain it can be
good or bad but I was in bleed all right
you understand what I'm trying to say
your career I didn't hear a word you
said yeah I want to turn your mic on for
a second because before we do the bright
line unless you're doing from whoever
it's not a name pronunciation we brought
so good the best bosses in history with
this limit of my office is your buyer
imagine coming home and he's like hey I
was working I think I'm fine
it's got open-ended - you question
pronounce this in there
very I wrong I shown and make sure if
you are described ready to blue pretty
that's hard to the nurses Leonce is
Howard bred for review no one needs that
us yeah there's no baby I be able to
build its horrendous - was chosen to
pursue this guy morally that's all I see
are mostly good morning out of you how
many people out there new today with
your top 5 go and be the wolves are born
liar hey Jack eleven question didn't Jon
Lovitz worst Jon Lovitz all was
everything is that was wrong I can use
an actress coming up for years
here's what I'm gonna do for our day I'm
gonna take you to many go ambition he's
still trying to do well again looks like
he's losing his mind and I'll briefing
other benefits loud sounds like there's
like a leg
god Alba see now this is the best I can
do even Iran Takashi's gray tank Iran
shell silver 5 dots Oh movie with you
boy run Ryan Santa like them was she
like like kind of spirit that was there
right I nailed that I contestant 4 hey
Bonnie
it's uh it's me Bobby D okay Robert De
Niro huh yeah I was so bad and make some
time put on
run five films it's in that four useful
it's Bobby's you know from Wisconsin and
uh I take you on a date to that Film
Festival that I pay for
I don't know where this is called I got
it
alright numbers and our final contestant
my name is Gandalf
can I have I went to a totally bailed is
horrible completely valid contestant
oh man oh wow we have a lot of broadcast
oh that's yes wow he really paid
attention to you guys over the years
thank you drew that's really cool man
thank you so much for going and taking
so much time out of your day to do that
that was like a cracking us cracking up
type video which I love which happens a
lot when we turn the cameras on we just
let everything rip and then occasionally
when we look at the editing and when
we're looking at which footage to use
it's like let's just actually leave this
in here in its entire let's just see
what the fans do if it makes us laugh in
front of to entertaining we give it a
shot and see if it works and it's worked
so yeah it makes you guys more relatable
to and more personable you know I wanted
to tell you guys something we got
Tyron Magnus and I talked after we
guest-starred on your show yeah he
thinks Tiffany is it smoke implicitly
huh
she's pretty cute no he wants to like
dill you know she's got she's got a
really cool boyfriend yeah he's a cool
guy
no diddling around I will sell you her
phone number for the sum of $10 you
don't have her phone
oh it's on you a phone number I need $10
I like you guys bye you guys I'm gonna
say one I finally get to do with it
you're on our turf we're finally the
onion turn I have I've never felt more
comfortable in an uncomfortable London
setting than I do
please tell me that you've had that
headshot on the show that's amazing
don't break don't destroy my stuff mark
that's like right off the set of Boy
Meets World
I am so good-looking so let's see what
you don't have to fix everything has to
be less than 15 minutes copyright strike
I now present you the headshot maybe the
first headshot of the real Ryan right
done look at that thank you I guess they
might have found out my other Haley's so
yeah sexy huh yeah yeah this is you have
a masturbate to this man but you have
dude is a shot up in his own apartment
it's like oh yeah it was me you going
outfit all right cool thanks guys huh
don't worry about me to hang out all
right guys well thanks for tuning in if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects and you
can also check out the schmoes now on
the schmoes know channel and what other
stuff is there that's cool to promote a
baby there's going to tell it everybody
out there where to find us and I'm gonna
give you a nice little back rub thanks I
was just absolutely on twitter at Rose
no Facebook same thing and make sure if
you want to check us out either on
collider movie news we're there go to
the Collider video as well as Jedi
Council all that cool stuff and go to
Fandango check out movie threesome he's
at Kristian harloff I'm at 5150 Ellis
and you carry a lot of tension in your
shoulders what's going on right in here
got you know I got into this fight with
a guy at Jamba Juice the others okay all
tell me that next time we got a guy